how did you get by the laser field in  the Great Hall  aha I have been working on something  it's a lot of money not just to and  you're gonna need a pool as nice as you  are  what are you down in line we need to  assemble a crack team just be prepared I  got the best of the best working on this  job top-of-the-line foam 22 tons steel  tool with 300 laser grids and a 24-hour  security team security cameras clear  damnit  be careful  we're in  broke into my vault  congratulations you're a dead man with  the street clear come on get these  people out of here let's go this town  you're lucky Cheng's just that quick  location you weren't clear for 90  seconds  okay to lure you're the best  well thank you Danny